で そういうふうには書かないんです
で 施すと言えば なんか人間にちょっとこのどこまでかというコントロールがあるんです
どこまで施しますかというと
それはもうどこまでもできるわけじゃないんです
もう最終的に言えば 人間自分の命を与えることはできる
それ以上は何もできないでしょうに
だから私は施しを実行しますと思った人が全部実行すると
自分が命を与えることで終わっちゃうんですね
それで全部終わっちゃいますから
それ以上何も成長ないんですね
お金もあげられるし 自分持っている知恵も知識もあげられるし
体力もあげられる でも切りがあるんですよ
これ以上はできないんだと
リミットがいつでもあるんです
そうすると成長は妨げるんです
でも 心の状態はそういう状態じゃなくて
お釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
漏無さぼりの心ない状態
むさぼりない状態というのはいくらでも成長できるんです
ですから 施しという言葉は使わない
で 次のドーサ ドーサというのは怒り
怒りの反対の言葉は慈悲なんですね
慈悲という言葉はそこに使わないんです
ただ怒りがない状態 怒りがない状態はどこまででも成長できる
その代わりだからポジティブ
あのあのポジティブの言葉は使ってないんです
これはものすごく成長できるんです
だから 老婆がない状態
怒りがない状態っていうのは
悟る人の心も同じなんです
だから悟るところまで成長できるんです
施しと言えば 施しを究極的に終わって悟ったということはありえないんです
それはもう修行の世界の話で
あのパーラミタですか
ハラミの世界の話で まあ大乗仏教では大変人気ある話ですけどね
いろんなストーリーいっぱいあって
命を与える話やら ああだこうだとかね
あの虎のなんとかいうストーリーありますよ
あの これはヴィヤッリージャータカという
あのテーラワーダ仏教ではないんだけどね
で 何でしたっけ 菩薩が修行中で
この森の中で この虎のお母さんが獲物を取れなくて
お腹が空いて どうしようもなくて
自分の子供を食べようとしているんだと
そこで菩薩はこれはいけないと思って
自分の身を投げて まあお母さんに獲物になって
なんて言いますか もう投げても
それでもう自分の身を投げて
それでも虎の子供たちを守ってあげると
で それなんとなくすごい一般的に考えちゃうと
すごいかっこいいストーリーなんですね
素晴らしい行者だと で
それはまた後でも 最近できた大乗仏教では全くものすごいへんてこりな解釈ありますけど
もう言ってるのはこの初期大乗仏教のストーリーなんです
だから混乱しないでほしいんです
初期大乗仏教というのは本当の大乗仏教なんです
日本でも最近できて いい加減にも何もわからない連中が作ったでっち上げた話で違うんです
その初期大乗仏教のストーリーで
まあですからまあどこでもあるストーリーで
このヴィヤッリージャータカというジャータカ物語なんです
そのジャータカ物語だからテーラワーダ仏教にもあるはずなんです
でもこのジャータカは抜けてるんです
だから言ってる道徳はちょっと危ないんです
意味がないんです で 抜けてるんで
だから私はそれ考えちゃうと
あの虎はどうしても他の動物を殺して食べなくちゃいけないし
そこで虎の子供2 3匹を救うために貴い人が死ぬと
菩薩が死ぬと 計算合わないんですよ
死んだあの菩薩が素晴らしい仙人で
人間で人間より行者だから
菩薩だから 人間よりも素晴らしい仙人がもうたったもう2 3
匹の虎の子のために命をあげると
じゃあそれで直りますかというと
また次にあの虎のお母さんがまたお腹空くんです
1週間経ったところで
だから問題は解決してないんですね
ただ損しただけ 自分が生きてたならもっと修行できるのに
2 3匹の虎は死んじゃっても
それよりも大したことないんですからね
どうせ死ぬんだからね
どうしたっても寿命が終わっても死ぬし
この前にも死ぬかもしれませんし
誰かに皮を取るために殺される可能性もあるし
中国人いたら薬のために殺す可能性もあるし
でもどっちかわからないし
だからあの虎の子たちが大きくなって
人類は救うならば あるいは人類だけなくても動物のね
救う そういう尊い未来があるんだから
やっぱり育てなくちゃいけないと思うならば
それは話は別ですけど
その何もなくてもう身を投げると
まあ話は嘘だから別に大したことないんだけど
この嘘の話でも作った場合は
やっぱりどうところもわかってないんです
そのストーリー作った人が
それに気づいた後の大乗仏教の人々は
それはもう観音様がこの菩薩の修行を試すために
そういう風な現象が現れて
そこで自分を身を投げて
まあもうその修行を確かめたというふうな
またでっち上げた話に
そのでっち上げた話を作るのは
やっぱりストーリー自体がガタガタなんからなんです
同じ身を投げたストーリーって
テーラワーダ仏教のジャータカ物語にもあるんです
それはこのあるブッダが現れて消えたんですね
消えたら法もどんどん消えちゃったんです
王様が ブッダの教えを聞きたかったんです
聞いたらもうブッダが
もう誰か知ってる人がいますか？誰もいないんですね
それで法を聞けないならば
私が法でいることも意味がないんだと
聞いて 王をやめて森に入っちゃうんです
何もいりません そこで帝釈天がこの人はもう必死になって
この法真理を探してるんだと
だから教えてあげなきゃ
この人は途中で死んでしまっちゃいますと
かわいそう 最後のその人だけなんですね
この人類の中で仏教を聞きたがっているのは
それで彼がこのものすごい怖い鬼の形をしてくる
鬼の形をしてきて現れる
それはすごい鬼なんです
で あんた誰ですか？私はもう人食い鬼だと
この王様が何もこと あんたお釈迦様の教え
お釈迦様ではなく そのブッダの教え知ってますか？と
知ってますよ じゃあ教えてちょうだいと
教えられませんと 何ですか？と
私がお腹が空いて もうじゃあお腹が空いてるんだったら
いくらでも食べ物あげますから
何でもあげますから それはダメです
私は人食いだから人しか食べないんだと
あ それは無理ですよと
私はいくら王であろうとも
他の人を捕まえてあなたに食わせるわけにはいきませんと
で 次が私の命あげますと
ですから教えてくださいと
言ったらもうそれでもまず食べてから教えるんだと
言ったら菩薩側の菩薩なんですね
それお釈迦様の先生だから
食べてから教えて 食べたらお前私を食べるでしょ
だからどうやって教えるんですか？と
もう私はその時死んでるんだから
ですから先に教えてください
ダメです 先に教えられません
お腹が空いてるんだから
じゃあそれだったら何か工夫しなくちゃいけないんだと
そのいろいろ工夫するストーリー
いつでもテーラワーダ仏教になるんですよ
じゃあその問題なら何か工夫しようと言って
二人で考えて じゃあ崖に登るんです
菩薩が 崖 ですか じゃああなたは崖の下に待っていてください
私は崖の上に行ってお前の口に飛びますと
で 俺は間だい だからこの自分の身を投げてるでしょ？落ちたらもう自分が身を投げた
で まだ食べてないんだけど
その間で私にブッダの教えを教えてくださいと
という風なこの約束して
すごい知識的なストーリーなんですよ
話は中断しないし とにかくなんとか工夫して
そこで菩薩は崖に登ると
鬼が下の口はスリランカのお寺なんか行くと
たまにお寺にこの書いてるんですよ
絵とかね スリランカのお寺っていうのはなんかすごい美術館みたいなもので
絵はあまり綺麗じゃないんだけど
いっぱいいろんな絵を描いてるんです
その影響でスリランカの教会も教会に行ったらありとあらゆる壁にいろんなこのジェズ様の物語描いてるんです
で 椅子をいっぱい もうこの本堂っていうのはもう壁はもう白いところ一つもないんです
何か描いてる で そういうのを描いてるんですね
すごいお腹が大きい鬼が口を開けている崖の上に
菩薩が修行の修行している最中の形ですね
飛べる飛ぶ形で その間で法を教えるんですね
その時もこの鬼はやっぱり結局初めから帝釈天でしょ
どうせ人食い鬼鬼ではないんです
その人を救うために来るんですね
守ってあげようとしてくるんです
そこで彼が落ちるし 落ちちゃったら死んじゃいますから
もうちゃんと自分が手でその人を捕まって命を助けてあげる
でもその間で一つの偈文を読む
その偈文もスリランカだったら誰でも覚えているお釈迦様の教え
偈文一つでアニッチャーサーカーラという我々正式で唱える偈文なんです
向こうの正式なお経っていうのはちゃった二行だけ
アニッチャーサーカーラウッパトワヤダンミノウパジットワニルジャンティテーサンウーパサモースポ
それで正式終わり それを三回唱えるんです
すごい短い 何時間もトントントントン
三時祭とか何とか それはないんです
その偈文の意味は すべての諸行は無常であると
生まれて消えていくんだと
パーダワヤダンミノ で
そこから解脱した方は平安であると
それだけ だからもう短いんだけど
真理はそのまま入っているんです
アニッチャーワタサンカーラ
デフィニットリ サーテンリー
確かにサンカーラ現象はアニッチャー無常である
人がそこに死んでいるんだからね
ですから確かに現象は無常である
現象の法則は生まれることと消えることであると
生まれて消えてなくなっちゃうんだと
どんなものでも テーサンウーパサモースポ
この循環から脱出することこそ平安であると
それでそれを三回唱えて我々帰ります
で その偈文を唱えるんですね
この帝釈天が 帝釈天のすっごい人気あるみたいで
その偈文が お釈迦様が亡くなった時の帝釈天がその偈文を言って自分の悲しみを表したんだと
そういう言われがありまして
そこで鬼が落ちる落ちた瞬間でちゃんと捕まって
で 殺して殺して食べないんですね
そうすると道徳を成り立たせるんですよ
そこで何言ってるんですかというと
真理を知ることは命より大事ですよ
何とかして一日でも生き延びようとするんじゃなくて
今死んでも真理を知りなさいと
無駄に生き延びることは何も意味がないんだと
あなた仏教を勉強しちゃったら廃人になりますよ
言ったっても それだっても
それでも仏教を勉強するというのを道徳を言い足ってるんです
だから王様は王様そのまま捨てるんです
千財産捨てても 国の王
何て言いますか 王位を捨てても
真理を知ってることこそ
生命には大事なものだと
王になるのは人間で言ったんだから
輪廻の絡みればもう大したことじゃないんだから
そういう道徳を表すために
そういうちっちゃな物語を先生物語を作ってるんですね
だから危なくはないんです
そのストーリーは 子供たちに教えたって
でも虎の物語は僕は教えませんし
あれは危ないんです そういうことで
この命取りストーリーはありますけどね
で 道徳的に危なくならないようにちゃんと気をつけているんです
余計な話にいっぱいなりましたけど
ですから この施しとなったらアローブムトン
代わりに施しと書いたらなんか成長ないんですよ
施しと言ったっても 最高にできるのは自分の命を捨てることしかないんだから
あまり意味がないんです
ですから 日常生活の中で
あまり欲張らないで 自分は余分に持っているものはみんなと分かち合って生活しなさいというぐらいで
ダーナ布施の話は終わるんです
それは先進者としては使わない
真理としては使わない
その時はアローバ むさぼりのない心
その状態だったらいくらでも成長できる
ものすごい微妙に気をつけてそういう用語を使っているんです
アドーサの場合も同じく怒りがない状態は育てましょうということになっていて
慈悲といったら他人の生命に対する慈悲なんですね
それはまあ生命 すべての生命に対して慈悲の心が出たらそれで終わり
でもアドーサはさらに
成長することはできるんです
ですから このここに慈悲の慈悲が入らないんです
この代わりにアドーサ
慈悲の慈ですね メッタこの場合は
そこでそれより私が言いたがっているのは
そういうことというよりは
我々は何かいいことをする
しようとする 仕事でもいいんですよ
家庭の問題でも仕事でもいいんです
立派にしたいと思うならば
その仕事をする時は怒りでできない
欲でできない その時は自信があって
サティがあって ちゃんと判断力があって
欲がなくて怒りがない状態で行動しなくちゃいけない
そうすると 結果として欲の結果が得られるかもしれません
子供はいい大学に入れて欲しがっちゃう
それはすごい欲の目的なんですよ
それでもその道が欲ではできないんです
すごく忍耐力があって
ものすごく知恵があって
丁寧に子供を育てていかなくちゃいけない
結果としていい大学に入るかもしれません
ですから 成功の道 どんな道でもあろうが
成功の道は先進者でないとできない
じゃあ次に行きます 次の言葉はタッラマッジャッタタ
これからものすごく難しいのを説明する
タッラマッジャッタタ
これはこの純粋に仏教の言葉なんです
で なかなかこのインドのサンスクリット語やらインドにあった言葉になかったみたいんです
例えばドーサっていうのは怒りだから
これはお釈迦様が生まれる以前からずっと昔からもう言葉の中にあるんですよ
怒りも漏婆も欲も ですから
インドで宗教の世界で使っている言葉をお釈迦様が借りて用語として使っちゃうんです
たまにその人類が考えたことがない概念の場合は
自分で新しい言葉を作らなくちゃいけないんです
このタットラマッジャッタタっていうのは一つのそういう言葉なんです
なんか言葉というよりはなんか表現みたいな言葉なんですね
訳は何でしたっけ？注者
そのタットラっていうのは
あの そこに そこ  そこにというか
そこにここにでもいいんですけど
その 一応そこに マッジャッタタっていうのは
この日本語でもそういう言葉がないんですね
なかなか これ仏教だけの言葉だから
もう英語でもない まあエクアニミティという言葉ありますけどね
エクアニミティ まあこういう風にそこに
あるいはそこに中立的になるという
という意味で取ってみてください
中立的になると いわゆるそこにというのは
その瞬間でやること その対象
いつでも我々は何かしているんだから
心で我々は何かしようとする
このしようとすることについて中立になる
いわゆるどこにも あの
何て言いますか 偏らない
偏らない状態 対象について偏らない状態
タットラマッジャッタタ
ですから中立とでもいいんですね
で 漢文で者という言葉を決めちゃったんだから
ウペッカーの場合は で
こっちも注者と書いているんですね
で 言葉一つ決めるのはいいんだけど
そうすると訳は簡単なんですけど
意味は通らないんですね
ウペッカーが出るたびに者が入れる
慈悲喜捨にも者入れちゃう
でも一つ一つ意味がそれなりに違うんです
ですから これはこの またそれも行動的な状況なんですよ
私たちは何か正しく行う場合は偏ったらダメでしょ
きちんとその仕事をしなくちゃいけない
仕事自体に集中してやらなくちゃいけない
偏ったらもううまくいかない
たとえ料理する時でも
その何かの特別な料理がしなくちゃいけない
その場合は それにはちゃんと状況を把握して
どんな順番で どういうふうに物を材料をまとめて温めた方がいいかということはまた決まってあって
そこはものすごく感情も何もなく
もうその客観的にその仕事をちゃんとやって終わると完璧な仕事になるんです
なんとか偏ったら 例えば食べる人のことを考えちゃうと
子供が食べるんだと思ったら
そのそこに料理が偏ってしまっちゃう
大人が年取っている人が食べるんだと思ったら
そこに偏ってしまっちゃう
そうすると その料理自体は完璧な作品にはならないんですね
ですから偏らないことはすごく大事なんです
で偏ると人間の感情で偏っちゃうんですね
で 大体結構我々仕事をなぜ失敗するかというと
その偏り方なんですよ
どこかに偏ってしまっちゃう
その瞬間で精神性から外れちゃうんですね
それで仕事もうまくじゃない
いわゆるもっと違う言葉で言えば
この何かやる場合は 心はすごくクールな状態でやらなくちゃいけない
なんかイライラ状態で何もできないんですね
文章を書くにしても 仕事をすることにしても
すごく落ち着いたクール状態
落ち着いている状態 落ち着いている状態でもいいんですね
何のことなく落ち着いてその仕事をする
そうするとうまくいく
仕事する途中でちょっとでも神経がかかっちゃって
ちょっと指が揺れるようになっちゃうとうまくいかない
そこで仕事はどんどん
あの 何て言いますか リターゲティング
まあうまくいかなくなっちゃうんです
スピードが遅くなっちゃうんです
ですから 何時間かかる仕事であろうか
あの落ち着いている状態はちゃんと守っていると
仕事はできると それ進む場合は
仕事をできるという場合はできたという場合は
いつでもその瞬間にその人はクールでいたんです
すごいクールで中立的でいたんです
だから 中立的でクールな状態がなかったならば
何もできない 例えばこの針に
何て言いますか 糸を通してくださいと
苛立っているとなかなか通らないんですよ
そこで回 回 回ぐらいやったところで
もう糸が入ったと その入ったという瞬間で瞬間でもクールなんです
だからずっと苛立っている状態にいることもできないんだから
心に 心はものすごく変化する
そこでほんのわずかな瞬間
まあ落ち着いて 糸の穴も糸
針の穴も糸も取って見られる瞬間出てくる
その時体も落ち着いている
そこで通ると だから もともとクールな人だったら回目で通るかもしれませんし
だからすごく苛立っている人に針に糸を通ってくださいと言っちゃったら
これ回ぐらいチャレンジするかもしれませんだけど
それでも通った瞬間になると
その瞬間だけクールなんです
ですから そのタットラマッジャッタタという心象がないと何一つもできないんです
だから この行動的な心を作るために一つ必要な大事な条件なんです
明るい 行動的な 活発的な心を作ろうと
いわゆる成功する心 確実に成功する心を作ろうとするならば
タットラマッジャッタタ
中立性っていうのは確実に必要なんです
中立性 落ち着いている状態
クール状態 クールな状態
で 普通の人間が 例えばたくさん仕事を机の上に溜まっていると
山みたいに それを見て落ち着きが消えちゃう
ものすごい大変だな これ今日はできるわけじゃないと
そう ここで落ち着きがなくなりますから
仕事のスピードが落ちるんです
スピードを上げたければ
いつでもここで一つ一つ一つ一つ根気よくやればいいんです
それタトラマッジャタタです
それは発見しているのは仏教だから
なかなか言葉ないんです
ですから結局仏教というのは
ただお守りをぶら下げていたってうまくいくわけじゃないんですよ
試験合格の合格のお守りとかね
持っていっても だからといって自分が書く場合はすごい冷静な心で
余計なこと何も考えないで
ただ空な心で書けばいい
それからは簡単だと思いますけど
この英語の本でタトラマッジャタタISリガーデッドボースアズアンインテレクチュアルアンドエシカルウペッカーと
そのお坊さん書いてるんですね
インテレクチュアルいわゆる知識的に中立そう
エシカル道徳的に中立
その両方の中立性をタトラマッジャタタと言うんだと
知識的道徳的な中立性
これから次にあるのはカーエパッサッディとチッタパッサッディ
その 2つカーエパッサッディとチッタパッサッディ
これなんかいろいろ問題が私にはありますけど
カーエっていうのは普通のパーリ語だったらボディ身体という身体なんです
チッタっていうのは心なんですね
ですから そのまま見ると身体と心なんですけど
パッサッディは何でしたっけ？軽安
まあ軽い 柔軟 軽く 軽いという意味なんですね
普通言えばもう身体は軽くて心が軽くてという状態なんですけど
アビダルマテキストの説明はちょっと違うんですね
アビダルマの場合は心
これは心 これはこの他の心想の軽さ
軽いということを取っているんですね
いわゆるフィーリングとかね
考え方とかね そういうのは混乱しないで軽い状態になっていると
心も軽い状態になっていると
ですから この問題は私はどうかなと思いますけどね
それはこれで身体の軽さと心の軽さと取った方が別に悪くないと思いますけど
ブッダゴーサ長老からのそういう注釈書ではそう取ってないんです
経典ではそこら辺も説明ないし
まあその前にパッサッディって何ですかと見てみましょう
軽安という漢字がつけてますから
軽安というのは軽というのは軽いということで
安というのは安定しているということで
パッサッディというのはすごくこの
軽いという軽いという意味なんですよ
いわゆる行動的に行動的になるために何が必要ですか？体が硬くて動かない状態だったら何かできますか？できないでしょ
ですから 何か私たちはすごい元気で行動的で何かする場合は
やっぱり体が軽く感じるんですね
で 軽く感じない 例えばこの部屋の掃除しなくちゃいけない
でも体がすごいだるい
動きた 動きたくない その時は掃除しないんですよ
そこで心が軽くなっちゃって
体も軽くなった瞬間で
じゃあ掃除しましょうと言って
さっさとその掃除をして終わっちゃう
歩く時でも 普段歩く距離でも
たまに体もうあまり心が行動的でない場合はもう歩きたくない
で 行動的な場合はもう歩きましょうと
何のことなく歩く ですから
この行動になる前に必要な精神状態
この軽さ 私はそれ体と心の軽さでは別に悪くないと思いますけどね
アビダンマテキストは心の説明だから
もう厳密にこの心だけの軽さですよと言ってるんですね
それちょっとわからないですね
ですから このカーヤパッサディ
チッタパッサディの説明は
まあそれほどもう考えないで
パッサディという意味だけ考えておきましょう
ケーヤン 軽さ ですからこの軽いという心想が生まれる
あ そういうわけだ この体を使ってないのは心想だから体には関係ないと
心想というのは心のものだからそうやってるでしょうと思います
でも まあ心が軽い場合は時は体も軽いんです
すごく軽いんです 行動的な場合は
どんな重い体でも我々は動かしますからね
子供見るとよく見えるでしょうね
子供にとっては何か面白くなくなったら
その場ですぐ座るでしょ
もう動かない もう抱っこして運ばないと
だからもう10分あれば何回座るかわからないんです
どこか連れて行く場合は
で 子供だってこの連れて行くんだけど
お母様が手を引っ張って
子供にとって面白くなくなってくると
そこで座り込む で またなんとか強引に連れて
またまた座り込むと そこで自分にとって面白い場合は 30
分であろうが 1時間であろうが走り回る
だから子供の体の疲れっていうのは
そういうふうに全然当てにならない
面白くない場合は ものすごく子供が疲れる
面白い場合はもう大人が疲れるんだけど
子供は元気 それで子供を工夫して扱う場合は
子供はいつでも椅子とやりますから
座り込んでもうもう座り込んで
もう泣く 言うこと聞かない
で だから何とかして何とか心を面白くしてあげれば
また元気になって また動かないと
座り込んでいる椅子とやってる人が立ち上がってまた走り出します
ですから この それはすごく明確なんですね
子供の心の状態を見ると
この体の関係はね 面白くなくなると
体も子供は別に嘘をついているわけじゃないんです
本当に動けないんです
その時は ですから私たちにも同じことで
面白くないとなかなか体も動かせないし
頭も動かせない 例えば頭だけ使って仕事をする時でも
その仕事自体面白くないと
頭は硬くて硬くて何もアイデアが出てこない
面白くなっちゃったらすぐアイデアが出てくる
だからいつでもこの この
あんまりこの 何真面目というんですか
この クソ真面目で生活するとうまくいかないんです
で どんな大事な仕事であろうが
よく冗談言いながら もういろいろね
ふざけて もうふざけてっていうのは本当にふざけるっていう意味ではなくて
まあいろいろ軽く明るくやった方が効率は一番いいんです
真剣に真面目で この顔もものすごく硬くしてやる人はいい仕事はしないんです
この小さな子供たちの教室を見ても
もうなんか何かやってる子供たちの方がいつでも頭が良くて勉強もできる
ちょっと暇だったら何かやってしまうんじゃ
そういう子供たちがやっぱり
やっぱり行動的で勉強もよくするんです
ですから この それを大人になっても
いく歳取っても忘れてはならないんですよ
常に心と体が明るい状態で持ってくる
明るくなくなったら何とかして明るい状況を作ればいいんです
そうするとまた 例えば同じ繰り返し仕事だったらどうしてもつまらないでしょう
同じことを何時間もやらなくちゃいけないと
もうつまらなくなってくる
つまらなくなるとすぐ体が硬くなってくる
で ストレス溜まる もう肩も凝る
あっちこっち痛みが出てくる
で どんどん暗くなっちゃう
どんどん仕事しづらくなっちゃう
そう面白くなくなってくるなと思っちゃうと
すぐ何とかして まあちょっと遊んで
ちょっと心変えちゃって
明るくして また進めればいいんです
そうすると仕事を始めた時も明るいし
四時間ぐらい仕事して終わった時でも明るいし
疲れていない だから我々はこの心の明るさを二十四時間保てるようにした方がいいんです
いつでもすごく気持ちよく明るくいると
その明るさ 軽さとかここで書いてるんですけど
そのけいあんとかいてるのはそういうものなんですね
私が言いたいのは この心がだるい時
必ずしも体もだるいです
体がだるい時も心はだるくなりますけど
体のだるさっていうのは
まあちょっと運動すればなくなくなりますからね
ですから心のだるさはよくない
心は常に明るくて柔軟性があるようにと
次には柔軟性ですよね
カエパッサ チッタブッサ
次にあるのは何？軽快性
カエラフタ チッラフタ
ほとんど同じ言葉なんです
ラフタ こちらにカエとチッタと二つ入ります
カエラフタ チッラフタ
で ラフタは本当にラフタっていうのは軽いという意味なんです
こちらでは軽い意味 パッサでは軽いという意味ではないんです
落ち着くという意味なんです
ホッとするという意味なんです
パッサって まあこの向こうのことを例えれば
この太陽があると暑いでしょう
それで日陰に入ると何となくホッとするんです
日本の夏はちょっと無理ですけど
向こうだったらもういくらもう暑くても日陰に入っちゃったらもう涼しいんです
そうするとすごくホッとするんですね
そんな感じなんです パッサっていうのは
で こちらで言えば 我々は外から歩いてきて
冷房ついてる部屋に入ると
入った瞬間でなんとなくホッとするんですね
そのホッとする感じ パッサっていう
ラフタっていうのは軽いという意味も厳密に軽いって意味
で こちらのことは軽快性と書いているんですね
次には柔軟性ですね ムドゥタ
カエムドゥタ チッムドゥタ
ムドゥっていうのは柔軟性なんですね
で 心の柔軟性 で ムドゥ
あのソフトという意味なんですね
ソフト 英語で言えばソフト